-My next guest has been selected
to five NFL pro bowls
and is one of the greatest tight
ends to ever play the game.
On Sunday, he won his fourth
Super Bowl ring
and his first as a member
of the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
Here is one of our favorites,
Rob Gronkowski.
Gronk!
-What's up, Jimmy? I got
to give a cheers to that, baby.
-Come on.
-Super Bowl champs.
-I got to say, buddy,
I was so happy for you.
Congratulations, first of all.
I was happy just from
the first touchdown.
When you caught that,
I go, "That's it.
That's all I need.
That's the win right there.
Just take that."
And I'm just so psyched,
'cause you know we love you.
And you're just fun
every single time.
And you're so -- I just --
Everybody loves you.
Everyone's rooting for you, pal.
And then you announced
your retirement,
and I go, "Yeah,
I guess I'm down with that."
I just want you to play forever.
But I'm like,
"Okay, I understand.
He's smart.
He wants to get out."
Then you end up on
"Masked Singer."
You're the white tiger
on "Masked Singer."
Gosh, what a weird year.
It is so fascinating.
You went from White Tiger
to winning the Super Bowl.
How does it feel --
I know you're doing
a bunch of interviews.
Has it sunk in yet?
You're a four-time
Super Bowl champion, bud.
-Yes, you know, it really
hasn't sunken in yet.
Yeah, I've been just talking
to my friends and family,
I'm like, it feels like surreal.
Like, it feels like, you know,
like it didn't even happen.
But it did happen.
Like, it just happened
with like a blink of an eye.
I just remember being traded to
Tampa Bay like it was yesterday.
And then a whole season
has happened,
with the whole pandemic going on
and everything.
It's just been an amazing ride.
It's been an amazing journey.
And it's actually
just incredible.
Like you said, I was the white
tiger on "Masked Singer."
You know?
And I was talking football
on Fox for a couple weeks,
end of the last season.
And then I had
a Super Bowl party
last year at the Super Bowl,
and then I come back
out of retirement,
and then, you're right.
I'm like, "Whoa,
we're in the playoffs."
Like, this is an incredible
year. Back to the playoffs.
You know, the Bucs haven't been
to the playoffs since 2007.
And then all of a sudden, win
three away games on the road.
Washington,
they had a top-10 defense.
New Orleans, they beat us twice
in regular season,
with Drew Brees.
We go there, they have a top-10
defense, beat them,
and then go to Green Bay, you
know, with that tradition there,
and just win
versus the MVP, Aaron Rodgers.
It's just an incredible journey.
And then go to the Super Bowl
at our home stadium,
first time ever,
and win it all, man.
It's been an incredible ride.
And it's been surreal, man.
-You caught two
touchdown passes,
and of course, you had
to do the Gronk spike,
which is awesome and hopefully
trademarked and whatever.
And, dude, that should be an
alcoholic beverage,
the Gronk Spike.
-Oh, yeah.
Dang, that's true.
-You just put a little spike
in your juice,
in your orange juice.
-That could be dangerous.
-But it's Gronk Spike.
It could be dangerous.
-I know.
-It could be fun.
-Yeah.
-Dude, start talking to people.
You know who to talk to.
-It could be deadly.
I love it.
-Yeah.
But, dude, look at the spike.
Please show this thing,
because I love it.
It's just extreme!
And you go for it.
-Oh.
-If I did that,
and I really practiced,
and I spent like
probably, you know,
10 years of my life
focusing on that,
here's what would happen
with me. I would spike it,
and it would probably bounce
and hit me in the helmet.
And it would be
all over the Internet.
Is there a way to throw it
so that it doesn't
go back in your face?
-Well, I got two bloopers
in my life before.
But the way to throw is you just
put your palm on the football,
and then, you know, with a good,
great grip using your palm.
And then when you bounce it,
you kind of bounce it
with the belly of the football,
you know,
the big part of the football
where it sticks out.
And then it hits the ground
high, with full potential.
And then that gives it its best
chance to bounce the highest
is when it hits off the belly.
But I've had it before
where it has came back at me
and hit me
right in the you-know-where.
You know, the gonads.
And I was like, "Ooh."
-Wait, I don't know
what you mean.
What do you mean by gonads?
Let me google gonads. Siri.
-Yeah, gonads, it's, you know,
a little slang for --
-Siri.
Siri. What are g--
Siri. What are --
[ Both laugh ]
I don't know
what I'm talking about.
-Yeah, I don't know
if Siri knows --
If Siri knows what gonads are,
I mean --
-This is nothing but perfect.
The photos, every photo of you,
you look great.
You and Tom, there's a picture
of you guys taking in
the Super Bowl win together.
How does that relationship work
between you and the quarterback,
you and Tom?
Do you guys -- When you first
started and you met him,
did you have to like go hang out
with him after practice?
Did you go see movies?
What'd you do?
-[ Laughs ]
It's a great question.
You know, as a rookie,
it's a little,
you know, it's a little
difficult task.
I mean, it's kind of hard
to, you know, get yourself in
and build up that chemistry
with the quarterback.
But when I was a rookie,
actually, Tom --
When I got into the league,
Tom was actually still older
than I am now.
He was 32 years old
when I started playing.
And I'm only 31 right now.
So that's pretty incredible.
Like, I retired,
came back, came to Tampa,
and I'm still not even his age
when I first met him,
which is incredible.
-That's bizarre.
-But like --
Yeah, obviously,
when I first met him,
like I was like, "Ooh,"
you know, like --
You know, it's Tom.
Like, it just
this dream come true.
And then I just saw
the way that everyone worked.
And when I came in as a rookie,
I was open-minded
just to get it done,
whatever I had to do, you know,
to be respected,
to get out on the field,
to get some playing time.
And let me tell you,
he works you.
He grinds you sometimes.
Like, he can get you, too,
like, man, like --
-Right?
-He wants me to keep going?
He wants me to keep going?
I already did 50 routes.
Like, oh, 10 more?
Like, and he won't take a no.
-Your first three Super Bowls
came with the Patriots.
Have you talked
to Belichick at all?
-No, I have not.
-You haven't received
any voicemails
of somebody going like [Growls]
-[ Laughs ]
No, no, I have not.
-[ Chuckles ]
You have to call that guy.
Come on. You got to get him
on speakerphone right now
and be like, "Yo!"
-You give him a call.
He was on your show before.
-I'm afraid of him!
I'm afraid of him.
I'm not going to call that dude.
Are you kidding me, man?
Hey, we love you, man.
Keep it up and just, I don't
know, keep being awesome.
I'm sure we're gonna see you
back next season.
You have to.
-Yeah. Yeah, hopefully, man.
I don't see why I won't be
back with the Bucs.
But we can have a great team
coming back, too.
Obviously, we just won it all.
Super Bowl LV champs.
Tampa Bay Buccaneers, baby.
But, you know, it's already two
days, you know, past the game,
and I'm already thinking, like,
"Man, what's it going to be like
next year?
Can we make it back?
What do I got to do?"
So, that's already in my mind.
Pretty crazy.
-Keep us guessing.
Keep us guessing.
I don't know
what you're going to do next.
-Maybe I'll retire again.
Hey, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Maybe I'll retire just so
I don't do training camp,
'cause training camp, like --
-That's the worst part.
-Yeah.
-Brilliant.
-Training camp, like --
Yeah. And then I'll come back
like oh, oh,
a week before the --
"Hey, will you guys
take me back?
Okay, yeah, yeah,
I'll come back. Yeah.
Oh, it's game time?
Oh, perfect."
-Congratulations.
Enjoy it. Enjoy it.
You worked hard. Enjoy it.
Thank you so much
for doing our show.
I appreciate it, buddy.
-No problem, man.
-Four-time Super Bowl champion
Rob Gronkowski, everybody.